Chloe and Tristan celebrate truths
second birthday
amid the coronavirus quarantine as Kylie
and Travis are courting teen together in
Palm Springs exes j.lo and Diddy
reunited virtually and liam hemsworth
he's sharing that Easter thirsty trap
this is easy live at home okay so this
weekend was true Thompson's second
birthday and we know the
kardashian-jenner is they throw even if
she's turning two it would have been
this lavish over-the-top themed birthday
party of course because of the pandemic
the entire family is practicing social
distancing and so they had to celebrate
a little different this year didn't they
yeah they went Chloe's still made sure
that true had a very special birthday
there were obviously a lot of lavish
balloons that were scattered all over
what looks to be a bedroom that you
could see true like you know playing
around and then of course with top of
the balloons they had a bunch of trolls
birthday cakes for her and it was cute
Chloe and Tristan both took turns
holding true while she blew out her
candles so still making sure that she
had a fun second birthday but I can't
help but to think of what that party
would have looked like you know right
had you not be I'm also thinking about
the the fact that obviously true got to
celebrate with both her mom and her dad
and it was just the three of them kind
of special she's young I'm not sure how
much she'll remember but like what an
interesting bonding moment for Chloe
interested I mean obviously they've been
through so much I feel like hell and
back like I feel like based on what I
see on Keeping Up with the Kardashians
they're in a friendly place now
especially with the rest of the family
we saw Kim take Tristan out to dinner
when they were in New York so I think
everything's cool but like the
quarantine is forcing them to really
just come a long time as a family it's
crazy I know a lot of people keep joking
around on social media that like
therapists are gonna like need to draw
up a lot of divorce papers at quarantine
and whatnot but I feel like it
opposite for Chloe and Tristan in the
sense that this quarantine could
possibly make their bombs stronger I
mean obviously we know the first and
foremost true is their priority they are
really great examples of co-parenting
and writing that book and even even
Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott are also
you know really great at co-parenting
and making sure that their child is at
the forefront of everything that they do
so I mean I don't think that Chloe and
Tristan will ever get back together I
know the whole statement to make I just
think that there's too much in the past
to have a clean clean slate but I think
what they're doing with true is amazing
and I think that this time together as a
family of three is going to be really
special for them because think about
both Tristan's you know schedule as an
athlete and then also Chloe schedule as
Khloe Kardashian scribe her a
businesswoman a mom like an entrepreneur
a reality TV star all the things that
she has going on it's very rare to get
this quality time together in the same
place with those people that you love so
you know I think it's I think it's
nothing but good things
crazier things have happened I feel like
and I could see in what world maybe one
day that happens we talk about because
this time they shared a daughter
together and but I will say also at last
week keeping up Chloe had admitted to
her mom that she hasn't dated anyone
since Tristan if she ever will she's
ready Chloe has honest
Chloe has one of the big I don't know I
can't call her up but from what I see on
the show texting her she just has this
big heart and she she loves hard but she
gets hurt hard and when she gets hurt to
the magnitude of what she's been through
it's it's I it's only normal for her to
have you know be taking this time to
just be all about herself be all about
her daughter and not really focus
the dating scene if anybody's gonna get
back together it's gonna be finally in
trucks you think like they're also
writing the book on co-parenting I feel
like you know obviously they had their
mom Chris and Robert Kardashian before
he asked as models right of like what
this could look like and how successful
it can be Oh Kylie and Travis are also
quarantined together they're in Palm
Springs but with stormy and also Kris
Jenner so like it's a family affair they
posted a video over the weekend or
they're like making pizzas out in the
back of it because you know that's what
they do and so it might be the most
lavish shot home that you could be
coring tuning in it's like but like so I
guess the question is like can't exes
quarantine together more importantly can
you quarantine with your mother-in-law
like Chris is there to hang out with
Travis and like the kids ready when you
are at a mansion there are multiple
rooms you can escape to and yes you can
absolutely if you put my ex a hundred
square feet it's not gonna work but like
also when you have a child involved it
is different and I can't speak for you
know first-hand experience with that as
I do not have any kids but when you have
that child involved you make it work and
really at the end of the day Travis
kindly seemed to be really great friends
I'm not talking that's how they started
off in the relationship first as best
friends and you know as they work
through their own personal issues that's
what that's where they're at right now
I feel like also Kylie has been
preparing for a quarantine like this
ever since she got pregnant with stormy
she even said who's that home at like
four months and so it wooley prepared
her for this moment I feel like there's
only two people in that entire family
who would like actually thrive in this
environment and it's Kylie Kourtney I
just bought a loving life I not go out
on to do anything I don't have to talk
to anyone I get to stay inside with my
kids I mean
to your movie theater and go lay out at
your giant pool that's the size of
meanwhile meanwhile I'm getting cabin
fever over here cause I need to get out
oh my god well you know what if you need
entertainment while you're in quarantine
to us did you see Diddy's livestream
that neat okay okay okay take it away no
it's just like I don't know I don't know
how this happened I think it's because
the corner the quarantine is really
making everyone accessible everyone's
cooped up at home they want to hop up on
Instagram lad they don't care who's
throwing the party did he threw a party
though he kicked up what he called the
world's biggest dance-a-thon on
instagram live and it's to raise money
for health care workers on the front
line of the corona virus outbreak but
little did we know his ex JLo popped in
for the dance of thought it was which by
the way and JLo pointed this out did you
see did his beard I'm like he is
literally bunkered down right now he's
got this like salt-and-pepper like berry
grizzly beard it's wild I know and look
my hair's getting long my house slippers
I actually put today oh my god so brave
the ex is reunited would you make of it
I loved it obviously JLo and did you
dated many moons ago I mean we're
talking 1998 to 2001 like decades ago at
this point and they've always remained
really good friends we've seen you know
then be at the same events together and
in public I mean there's obviously no
bad both have moved on with their lives
I love a good reunion and the internet
loves a good reunion and I think it was
more so not the fact that they had this
epic reunion on Instagram live but the
fact that a rut also got involved in
this it also was like what if Diddy's
biggest
fans was the cutest thing in the world
let's take a look in case you guys
missed it
[Music]
hey Ron what's going on player player
here's my brother cheers yes she is
president dates and life to love to the
health care workers you know right now
it's crazy out there everybody everybody
has the family how's everybody doing
everyone some really really good we had
a beautiful Easter here already we had a
little Easter egg hunt yeah and she's
running around and jumping in the pool
and let's get an ask for anything more
you can tell that a rut stands Diddy a
little bit like he's a fair you know his
fiancee it was another era
like it was a completely different like
Versace
a green dress lifetime ago you're so
right look looks really bad look at that
looks like all these X's are
reconnecting and Quarantine like vermin
when Jennifer Aniston comments on John
Mayer's Instagram live a couple weeks
ago social media single like myself and
your rooms gently alone and you are
tempted to you know literally just have
any type of contact whether it be you
know someone on a dating app or someone
in your past like an ex but obviously in
this situation with JLo it was nothing
more than a friendly like Instagram
friend connecting into the live
situation it was an amazing surprise
though it looks like when Brad and Jen
reunited at the SAG Awards everyone it
kind of blew up because again with their
their relationship I hate to say it and
like you know tabloid I making a tabloid
thing but like it was just so iconic and
we followed their entire like love saga
you know so I think that's
to see them together again but we talked
about it was so star-studded like he got
so many people to hop on Instagram live
I won't place on maluma like in his fur
coat and I'm like okay we got everyone
in fact I you know I follow his every
move so I was like oh he was on this
live stream I was like I was like I
almost was holding my breath cuz I was
like what is gonna happen
my cousin is Oh Liz oh is she what I
think it was oh I think a party it might
do this was at Easter Sunday and so
she's like pulling out all the dancers
she starts denne she starts like getting
low like this I'm like girl what you
doing I'm like water you did is risen
so people online started kind of
dragging diddy a little bit because
hours later drain Michelle the model
popped up and she was twerking so we're
like oh so fans online basically say Oh
Liz Oh can't twerk or Draya can't he
literally had to go on Instagram story
to kind of clear it up which Liz Oh
reposted where he was like no no it
wasn't that Queen Liz Oh was Turkey
which we know she can do it was that the
song had expletives in it you know
that's the truth because immediately
after Ginny came and it kind of
interrupted her dance when she was
apologizing she realized it was for this
song not the dance because then she said
okay let's switch the song let's play
juice by Liz oh there's no T here why
was that more awkward than when JLo
popped up with a rod to talk to her ex
did he like the lizard thing I thought
was so awful it was a little awkward
because at first I thought it was
because of the twerking I understood it
was like Easter Sunday like he kinda
wanted to keep it you know for free
essentially because she I mean she was
genuine like I'm really sorry like I'm
so sorry I'm really that she
good yeah well someone who showed off
his goodies on instagram liam hemsworth
i'm gonna let you take this one okay and
gave us this thirst trap literally just
laying in bed perfectly sculpted face
with his scruff and like holding what
looks to be probably his coffee his tea
whatever the hell he was drinking out
here Sunday morning in bed and what was
the black-and-white picture of it like
it just it was majestic I double tapped
on it I sent it to a few people and I
did not comment on it but I want a sip
of whatever he comments my comments are
here okay I want to sip or whatever he's
drinking he looked so good and he was
encouraging everyone to stay in bed I'm
like say no more family this comes as he
also was on the cover of Men's Health
and you know obviously he's since moved
on from Miley a source recently told et
that Liam is happy with his low-key
girlfriend Gabriella Brooks and things
look to be coming up Liam though the man
looks good he's got this low-key
girlfriend no sores but also he kind of
had a rough end of his 20s and now he's
transitioning into his 30s and he tells
Men's Health he is on a frickin journey
I mean you remember that he lost his
house yeah now the wildfires apparently
got serve you for a kidney stone yeah
that was honestly one of the most
surprising parts about this entire men's
health interview is you know you
mentioned he looks good but he also
feels good which is like what's almost
more important in this sense because he
went through a journey literally with
his health
it all started you know obviously he was
very into a vegan diet which led him to
get a kidney stone which led him to have
surgery which then led him to rethink
this vegan diet but now he says he's
healthy he's good he's found this
balance he's he's working out he's you
know finding different things like ice
baths to help with his mental and
physical
health and you know that's that's like
that says priority now but it was a
pretty alarming you know interview
because it also makes you humanize with
someone who's this celebrity stature
like oh they're also like us they also
deal with very scary health issues too
and he even told men's health the lesson
that he learned coming out of his
twenties into his 30s and I gotta read
it verbatim because it's also I feel
like a lesson all of this could take
right now in this current situation
appreciating the little things
especially in times that maybe things
aren't going the way I planned or the
way I wanted things to go is the lesson
that he'd learn and I'm like preach man
don't we all though in our 20s you still
got a couple more years but girl in all
seriousness obvious and you're going
through unprecedented scary times right
now in this pandemic and I think it's
really helping everyone learn to
appreciate the little things more like I
found myself the other day listening to
birds chirping outside and finding this
sense of calm and peace and hopefulness
with it it's those type of little things
that bringing so much more joy these
days that I feel like once life resumes
back to normal whatever that is that we
are going to have a newfound gratitude
yes smaller things like that and
hopefully it'll just mean you can am
kind a better place since we're all
gonna be hopefully a little bit more
positive and grateful to be alive and
for all the things in our lives like you
know whether it's small things like
birds chirping or big things like or
small things like a freaking haircut I
never take that luxury for granted again
I'm sure how are you doing you resorted
to getting the Clippers now are you
literally pranaam my boyfriend had to
take a beard trimmer to cut the size we
haven't touched the top it's getting
really long which is why I'm now rocking
like these weigh you I
oh great you know I love you with the
long hair and like the scruff so I think
this look works for you but celebrities
are getting they're taken to drastic
measures I mean Hilary Duff she just
posted on Instagram she dyed her hair
blue she wasn't even just trying to
cover up gray hairs or diving roots she
full-on went blue maybe she's feeling
the Blues I don't know I maybe I took a
page out of her book it uh I just like
this is really honestly yes people are
resorting to desperate measures or
whatnot but it's also a really creative
time and maybe this was pure like hey I
don't have anywhere to be I don't have a
red carpet so I'm just gonna experiment
with this or you know you don't have any
acting gigs right now everything's
essentially scale so no one there's not
a studio telling you how to cut your
hair how to color it or whatever part is
you get to have fun and do what you want
I actually loved the blue hair and it's
literally by the time we're out of here
it's gonna be blonde again I already
know also be like Laura Molina the
country singer what she did is it was a
permanent dye it ends up washing out
after a few days and whatnot what's so
interesting and kind of comical is that
you know obviously when this pandemic
first started we saw things like toilet
paper and hand sanitizer flying off the
shelves now stores are struggling to
even keep my hair clippers on the
shelves here by NATO kids Oh what you
can't find a mail kit to save your life
now it's spa days all day every day at
people's homes now and also I want to
add to that list flower apparently
apparently everyone's baking up a storm
- so it's like self self care is so
important it's not even like making a
joke out of it and making sure obviously
our physical health is so important but
also our mental health as well if you
know if it means baking some cookies
facetiming a friend dyeing your hair
cutting yourself bangs
do what makes you happy right now or
buzzing your hair ball did you see :
Underwood he's back - I love it
do you see Courtney under what's
shocking new haircut so he posted this
video
girlfriend Cassie Randolph like about to
trim his hair and they don't trust
Cassie's with clippers I love you girl
but I would never let you near it not
here no no I ever turn out like : fans
only gets real but he posted the reveal
and it's like he's got a nearly bald
look with the hair on the side which you
know we can't trust anything that was a
real oh I thought he buzzed it well I'm
sure yeah well I don't think Colin's is
real although I will say that is like a
trend right now like an internet like
meme people doing the old man's haircut
you've seen on a lot of kids but anyways
whether that's real or not people are
bored on today three days ago
throwback I think that might be because
fun dressing up for Easter family mass
there it is and zoom in on this is a
case with my god that makes our job a
lot harder in that case I'm so glad my
FBI agent cohort was here for et live at
home today Cassie
thanks so much so good to see you you'll
be back tomorrow with some more tea on
the celebrities up until then I need a
PT on et until then I'm about to go make
another coffee girl you guys let's get
baby right ok I love you
ah that's watching and we'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]